please welcome Oscar nominee uma Thurman
all great films no matter what their
subject matter begin the same way when a
brilliant writer with a clear vision
sits down to work and begins to write
the nominees for Best Original
Screenplay are Paul Haggis
and Bobby Moresco for crash George
Clooney and grant Heslov for good night
and good luck
Woody Allen for match point Noah
Baumbach for the squid in the whale
Stephen Gaghan for Syriana
and the Oscar goes to Bobby Resco and
Paul Haggis for crack this is the first
Academy Award for Paul Haggis and Bobby
Moresco Paul Haggis is also nominated
tonight for cracks in the directing and
motion picture categories
just before during an emission mission
during the commercial break my sister
walked up to me and gave me my ring the
ring my mom's ring saying that she was
here with me and she really messed me up
Joe thanks a lot the red road Rex said
that art is not a mirror but it is a
hammer in which not a mirror to hold up
to society but a hammer which to shape
it and so I guess this is ours the eye
Bobby and I had the good fortune to to
speak to a lot of big media to I'm so
nervous to to win a few of these awards
recently as we've thanked everybody we
want to thank and so tonight I just want
to thank those people who take big risks
in their daily lives when there aren't
cameras rolling and when there aren't
people there to applaud and the people
out there who who stand up for peace and
justice and against intolerance and so I
dedicate this to them thank you very
much Tom Hanks for the Roughnecks to
followed by Jack Nicholson and the
announcement of the final award of the
evening the Oscar for the Best Motion
Picture